في الازمه الليبيه تتبادل اطراف الصراع
كثيرا لكن شيئا وحيدا يظل ثابتا معاناه
الليبيين احتدم النزاع القانوني باستمرار
وكانواه الصراع السياسي والعسكري ومن اجل
ذلك جاء دور لجنه سته زائد سته هي لجنه
مشتركه تاسست في مارس الماضي سته اعضاء من
مجلس نواب ومثلهم من مجلس الدوله والهدف
هو اعداد القوانين الانتخابيه وتجاوز
الخلافات التي كانت سببا في عدم عقد
انتخابات ديسمبر 2021 هذه اللجنه وعلى مدى
الاسبوعين الماضيين دخلت في مفاوضات مكثفه
في مدينه بوزنيقه المغرب وماذا عن النتيجه
رسميا تم التوافق على قانون الانتخابات
الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه في ديسمبر المقبل
لكن بلا توقيع على الاتفاق بانتظار حضوري
رئيس البرلمان عقيل صالح ورئيس مجلس
الدوله خالد المشري
تم التوافق بين اللجنتين لجنه سته زائد
سته من مجلس النواب ومجلس الدوله على
قانون لانتخابات الرئاسه وانتخابات
البرلمان
وننتظر في الايام القادمه
[موسيقى]
حضور السيد رئيس مجلس النواب ورئيس مجلس
الدوله
التوقيع او
البث في
الاتفاق النهائي في
بخصوص هذا هذا القانون
تحدث ممثل مجلس النواب الليبيه كما تابعنا
عن حضور رئيس المجلسين خلال الايام
المقبله لكن مصادر العربيه تفيد بان رئيس
البرلمان عقيل صالح غادر اصلا بوزنيقه
بسبب خلافات حول بعض بنود مشاريع القانون
القوانين ما هي الخلافات اذا هي ذاتها مثل
المره الماضيه الاختلاف بشان الشروط
الترشح للرئاسه وتحديدا السماح للعسكريين
والسياسيين من نظام القذافي بجانب مزدوجي
الجنسيه من الليبيين بالترشح للانتخابات
مجلس الدوله لا يريد ترشح شخصيات ليبيه
مثل قائد الجيش حليفه خليفه حفتر وسيف
الاسلام القذافي نجد معمر القذافي نفس ما
تريده حكومه البيبه والمليشيات غرب ليبيا
فيما يرغب مجلس النواب بمنح فرصه الترشح
لكل الليبيين دون اقصاء احد لكن حتى واذا
توافقت الاطراف الليبيه حول قانون
الانتخابات الاتفاق لن يكون ذا قيمه الا
بشرط
النص نص الاتفاق مهما كان كيبقى نص اذا لم
تواكبه اراده سياسيه حقيقيه
ليكون تكون هذا الاتفاقات عندها
الامكانيه باش تنزل على ارض الواقع
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات